on va voir parce que vous ce qui vous
dérange surtout gilles c'est la vidéo et
bilal a répondu lui cette vidéo mais
justement je vois cette vidéo cette
vidéo qui était une parodie sada un truc
on va en parler mais attendez attendez
guirec pour les téléspectateurs on voit
cette vidéo qui a posé problème
et cette vidéo fait sa part c'est une
parodie
voilà deux une vidéo qui avait fait
énormément le buzz sur les réseaux
sociaux d'une vidéo de joie qui célèbre
la fin en soi puisque c'est quelqu'un
qui dit qu'on était champion du monde et
qui ma foi ce juste après la victoire
garde la france regardait dû regarder
d'abord la vidéo initial regardez la
vidéo initial alors voilà est donc
derrière bilal avec ses amis quand on
fait un travail de juin regardez donc
c'était après la coupe du monde regarder
la france a vraiment alors gilles ce qui
vous pose des problèmes c'était cette
vidéo on voit que mine de rien ils sont
juste en train de après moi je moi je
vois la jolie c'est juste après avoir la
réponse de milad mais justement fait il
parle moi je quand j'avais vu la vidéo
je n'avais pas compris au départ mais
après j'ai vu qu'il parodier cette vidéo
c'est rythmé mais même moi je l'avais vu
à l'époque cette vidéo qui était très
drôle de deux garçons et c est ce que
vous vous dites toujours non après avoir
vu cette vidéo et que c'était une
parodie
oui j'entends les explications j'entends
voulait voir lire explications de bilal
d'abord avec plaisir la première a gardé
fait cette vidéo c'est une vidéo d'un
d'un jeune homme qui est hyper content
parce qu'on avait gagné la coupe du
monde l'été dernier la france a gagné la
coupe du monde l'équipe de france et il
dit voilà la france a vraiment souffert
on avait des attentats par sia temps à
parler après sautent de joie et d'humour
ou parce que voilà c'est bon enfin on
avait un bon moment pour la france et
c'est une vidéo qui est devenu très
générale que tout le monde a repris lip
dub et à fond et moi et moi y compris
voient la smcc en aucun cas malveillants
surtout pas on a tous souffert
c'est ce que je dis dans la vidéo c'est
quand on le parle j'y vois là on a bien
souffert mais on avait enfin une
victoire enfin un bon moment et on l'a
tous partager cette joie l'été dernier
moore alors alors
moi j'ai été très choqué par cette vidéo
je n'avais pas vu la vidéo d'hier à
l'avant et je me suis dit se [ __ ] de
la gueule des attentats ça m'a touché
donc vous aviez jean roy il devait pas
représenter un droit quand je vois son
explication quand j'entends son
explication
quand je vois le contexte je change et
je dis oui pourquoi parce que trop
souvent on veut prendre des petites
phrases des petits mots hors du contexte
c'est tellement facile aujourd'hui une
petite phrase lors du contact et on est
condamnée donc vraiment lorsqu'on a le
contrat que ça permet d'avoir du recul
et là je changeais je dis oui quand on a
les expliquer à cette vidéo seul est
tous passés haut la mère du garçon
laquelle roule il serrait que tout le
monde avait fait voile à des délires des
vidéos derrière pour voilà prêts lombard
odier
et c'est vrai que voilà après gilles
vous est ce que vous êtes convaincus
maintenant
non du tout et directe et d'un an
j'aurais surnom j'entends par abel
jamais j'entends parfaitement les
explications les tentatives les
tentatives louable de justification
d'effacement schaaf est dans le coup il
ya eu des tweets il ya la vidéo
pour moi on ne joue pas on ne manifeste
pas on ne s'exprime pas de cette manière
à propos des attentats
je vais vous dire sincèrement c'est un
peu sévère mais je vais le dire très
calmement ce que je ressens c'est tuer
deux fois les victimes d abord je vous
dis ce que je ressens gilles ne parlait
pas la place des familles gilbert bel
silence que vous êtes un an
en fait c'est très casse que vous faites
non non j'en ai parlé à la place des
femmes
gilles enfin vous voyez bien que c'est
une vidéo qui encense la france on vient
de gagner la coupe du monde ce jeune
homme qui ivre de joie la personne noire
qu'on voit à l'antenne est ivre de joie
tous les youtube heures et tous les
youtube buzz pour fait célébrer la
france ont repris les gestes que voilà
effectivement c'est pas très malin ça je
vous la corde et je suis bien d'accord
bilal vous savez quoi beeline l'a8 à 50
mètres d'un des lieux des attentats de
2015 il l'a vécu en plein en plein dans
en plein dans la tronche si vous voulez
donc vraiment c'est lui porter des
accusations qui se cache derrière tout
ça pardon on cherche des tweets on
cherche des vidéos armements c'est un
acharnement vraiment gilles vous qui
êtes journaliste je vous aime beaucoup
en plus tout en se maintenant essayez de
creuser un petit peu maintenant peu plus
de berrien un poil loin mer même si bien
sûr on respecte on est on est on
respecte bien sûr toutes les victimes
des attentats je pense que bill allociné
ans et là c'est le contexte après je
posais la question moi je dis bien sûr
et des gens qui vont dire c'est des
fausses excuses
tu as trouvé un moyen de s'en sortir
parce que tu veux absolument rester dans
le monde médiatique et tu veux pas que
la france était évident que deux sortes
de l'eurovision et regarder sa réponse
c'est pas mentir de toute façon j'ai
jamais triché à l'école parce que je me
faisais toujours cramer très rapidement
les alpes où j'ai essayé donc voila moi
j'ai voulu dire uniquement la vérité je
vais dire aux personnes aux personnes
qu'ils sont contrariés c'est que moi
juge juste un artiste chanteur et j'ai
envie de porter les couleurs de par là
je vais porter les couleurs de mon pays
à l'eurovision
j'en suis extrêmement fier alors voilà
donc bilâd